right here we have 65 blocks and you can
count them if you like but we can
represent them with the number 65. by
writing a six in the tens place we're
literally saying that we have six tens
and this is a ten this is a ten this is
another ten this is another ten this is
a ten
this is a ten
and this is a ten we have six groups of
ten and that makes sixty and then we
have five ones
five let's do that orange color
and then we have
five ones and you see them right here
one two three four five
so now let's do something interesting
well actually let me just first write
that down again just to emphasize it so
we can write down that 65
65 is equal to six tenths
six
tens
plus five ones
plus
five
ones
now let's do something interesting let's
start with 65 so let me write that down
again
so i'm going to start with 65
having trouble changing colors
we're going to start with
and i'm going to subtract
i'm going to subtract 40.
i'm going to subtract
40 from that
so what am i really doing here
well i'm starting with 65 i'm starting
with this and i'm subtracting four tens
and zero ones so let's subtract four
tens from here
so let's subtract
one
two
three
four
so i took away four of the tens so how
many tens do i have left over well i
have left over two tens so this is going
to be equal to two tens
and how many ones do i have well i still
have five ones
so it's still
i still have five ones and that makes
sense i had five ones i took away zero
ones so i'm still going to have five
ones and so what is this going to be
equal to so we can write
65 65
minus 40
is let me do that i want to do the ones
in that orange color
minus 40 is equal to another way of
saying two tens is by putting a two in
the tens place and a and then we have
five ones a five in the ones place so
two tens plus five ones or twenty-five